okay welcome to the live stream so much
to discuss today glad that you are with
me we will talk about a lot of different
things including the controversy that
has just absolutely devastated
devastated the progressive independent
media community I have been accused of
stealing intellectual property from
fellow progressive independent show host
Sam cedar lawyers are swarming like a
feeding frenzy to represent Sam to
represent me this could become one of
the biggest legal battles of the decade
and I will tell you what the hell I'm
talking about a little bit later but we
have a lot of other things to discuss
including that a new report implicates
Donald Trump in exactly the same crime
that Michael Cohen his personal attorney
former personal attorney has been
convicted of and will be going to prison
for and I will get to all of those
details momentarily if this is your
first live stream with me welcome these
are live contrary to the videos that we
upload which means you can participate
the best way to participate is by using
the super chat button that's the dollar
sign at the bottom of the chat window
super chat questions and comments will
be read and I will respond to them sign
up for membership we are actually mostly
funded by membership super chats are all
fun and games but when it really comes
down to funding our show it is
membership at WWJ back mancom I am
willing to open up the phone lines to
all of you fine folks if we get 10 new
members I'll talk about that momentarily
don't troll the live chat don't troll
the live chat don't throw the live chat
there are moderators they will ban you
it is free to ban we don't paper ban it
is unlimited banning at no cost which is
a really great thing and you can also
use the join button down below the video
window to become a YouTube channel
member all extraordinarily exciting
stuff so let's get directly into the
content if we can new report implicates
Donald Trump in the same crime that is
sending Michael Cohen to jail where to
even start with this
both allegedly lied to banks about their
net worth to receive a loan only one is
going to prison
president Donald Trump repeatedly
committed one of the same crimes that is
about to land his former lawyer Michael
Cohen in jail the New York Times
reported Monday we should really go
straight to the New York Times article I
try to avoid doing the oh I see why it's
gonna be hard to find exactly where in
this article this section is okay maybe
we'll go back to that will stick with
Think Progress for now
The Times report on Trump's long
troubled history with Deutsche Bank
includes allegations that he repeatedly
overstated his wealth to obtain
favorable loans from the bank the
reporting confirms some of Cohen's sworn
testimony that Trump misrepresented his
assets when it suited him The Times
reports that Trump overstated his
personal wealth by 2.2 billion dollars
when applying for a loan to build the
Trump International Hotel and Tower in
Chicago around 2005 five years later in
another incident a Deutsche Bank team
app tasked with investigating his
financial records reportedly discovered
that Trump was inflating the value of
some of his real estate assets by up to
70% Trump was seeking finance financing
for his Doral Golf Resort & Spa in Miami
Trump reportedly lied to deutsche bank
again in 2014 as part of his bid to buy
the Buffalo Bills football team
according to The Times and to
congressional testimony Cohen gave last
month this is an important point to make
about Donald Trump's taxes we've talked
a lot about how Donald Trump has not
released his taxes there may be
nefarious not that this isn't a fair use
but there may be more nefarious
things that would be uncovered if we
were to get a look at Donald Trump's
taxes but the truth is that seeing
Trump's taxes is more likely to reveal
quote merely and I say merely in the
sense because it's it's still
significant because of what we're
learning today Trump may not want to
release his taxes because he's just not
nearly as as rich as he has claimed to
be and and it's mostly an ego
thing we may at some point learn more
about that it was my experience that mr.
Trump inflated his total assets when it
served his purposes such as trying to be
listed amongst the wealthiest people in
Forbes and deflated his assets to reduce
his real estate taxes Cohen himself
pleaded guilty last year to a host of
charges that included lying on loan
applications to obtain a home equity
line of credit he will begin a 36 month
prison term in May Republicans on the
House Oversight Committee pointed out
Cohen's loan fraud after he testified
last month that he only lied to Congress
to protect Trump suggesting his bank
fraud made him an unworthy witness
meanwhile some Democrats on the
committee called on further criminal
investigation into Trump's financial
history this is not the first time Trump
has been implicated in potential crimes
as the sprawling Special Counsel
investigation into Russian election
interference has grown to include the
president's business and campaign
finance dealings Cohen testified in
federal court last August that he broke
campaign finance laws in coordination
with and that the direction of Trump by
coordinating hush money payments to
women who say they had affairs with the
then candidate and then we get into this
sort of almost mandatory paragraph in
all of these stories it is to judge the
Justice Department's long-standing
policy not to indict a sitting president
though that policy has never been tested
in court but the presidency is a fickle
shield with the 2020 election just
around the corner
Trump's legal woes could just be
beginning I want to make a general point
which I've been making on the show for a
while even if it's correct to impeach
and remove the President of the United
States even if there is a worthy case to
be made that the 25th amendment should
be used to remove Donald Trump from the
presidency uh
it's almost guaranteed not to happen and
even if it were it would at this point
realistically bleed over into Donald
Trump second term why does that matter
does that mean we should an impeach
Trump if he deserves impeachment of
course
we should to say we're not gonna bother
with impeachment is to say the president
is effectively above consequence for his
actions that can't be
that is not it was not the intention of
the founding fathers of the United
States but from a practical perspective
the most direct path to removing Trump
from the White House is just voting in
November of 2020 any of these other
mechanisms depend on Republicans
impeachment will depend a presume could
depend just on Democrats in the house to
start proceedings but it would require
Republicans in the Senate for the
removal of the president they've shown
no indication that they care about what
Donald Trump has or may have done so
just vote the guy out in November of
2020 the cabinet we've spoken to
multiple well multiple mental health
professionals who say Trump should be
removed via the 25th amendment he's
unfit to serve at this point in time it
is extraordinarily unlikely that you're
going to get a Republican cabinet to do
that so the most direct path to Trump
leaving is voting him out in November of
2020 and so when we read about Trump's
possible crimes and alleged crimes as we
look at new reporting from the New York
Times and and other media what you have
to remember is no matter what is
contained here we have a polarized stat
tribal I prefer Jonathan heights term
group --is-- it is so group --is-- in
nature that it is almost not totally but
it is almost a lost cause to count on or
expect Republican assistance in doing
what more and more voters know is the
right thing to do and with Donald Trump
seemingly immutable base of support
which seems to be somewhere between 32
and 35% like it's just not going to go
below that at this point in time we got
to just vote the guy out that's the most
direct path I know that there are some
in our audience who believe that Donald
Trump is going to use a bogus national
emergency or some other means to try to
maintain the present presidency let's
cross that bridge when we come to it
it's not something that we need to deal
with now voting from about
be faster than impeachment it will be
faster than using the 25th amendment
okay let me do a couple of Super chats
and then I do want to get to this
stunning stunning I don't even know what
to call it just devastating allegations
against me made by some viewers of sam
cedars majority report that we have an
intellectual property theft taking place
for which i may face consequences i will
get to that momentarily but let me first
do some super chats because people are
very very excited here i will welcome to
new YouTube subscribers channel members
Brian Wilkins and Gerwin Bergsma if we
get 10 new members during the stream
I'll open up the phone lines at 6 1 7 8
3 0 47 50 don't call now if you call now
it'll go straight to voicemail
and boy do we get some wacky voicemails
but if we get 10 new members either
people hitting the join button down
below or better we get a higher
percentage of the revenue if you sign up
on our website at wwlp.com slash
membership we have a coupon code
available this is 20 20 the coupon code
this is 20 20 will save you 40% off of
your membership your name will pop up on
a screen over to the left here
I will Thank You profusely but most
importantly if we get eight more new
members I'll open up the phone lines and
people will be able to call in so let's
make that happen okay Doug Condor asked
mr. P doesn't the fact that Trumper
remains in office longer mean that he
can do even worse damage shouldn't he
leave before 2021 I want him out today
yes every day Trump is in the Oval
Office is more damage that he does but I
just don't see a path to getting him out
any sooner than January of 2021 at this
point in time yeah impeachment yes 25th
amendment I think they're going to take
a year and a half and were a year and a
half from the election so I don't
disagree with you I just think
practically speaking it's just time to
vote that's it sixes sends a $6 and
sixty-six cent
super chat I think I understand what you
did there Trump has committed at least
five capital offences espionage treason
and the deaths of the kidnapped children
molar better acknowledged that yeah I
wouldn't count on that I wouldn't count
on that Bush honorable with a dollar
ninety-nine super chat says simply 1.99
Thank You Joseph didn't psa's din zis
says hey David you do such great work
what is your favorite politically themed
music my favorite political artists are
Radiohead Bad Brains and void man I
don't I don't know too many bands I
follow that are politically themed and I
follow so many Argentinian bands that
they're politically themed sort of but
related to Argentinian and Latin
American politics so it wouldn't really
be relevant for our audience but I don't
know I mean Rage Against the Machine
hasn't even I don't even know if they're
still together but they are politically
themed and that's a great band erling
Thune sensei twenty Norwegian kroner
super chat with just a thumbs up thank
you very much erling Sam Dean sends a
twenty Australian dollar super chat
g'day David now that Australia has
banned any white supremacist or anyone
with ties whatsoever to white supremacy
groups for that matter entering the
country could that mean that Trump is
ineligible to even visit uh I think that
Trump can go to Australia if he wants to
I don't think that that's going to work
for keeping Trump out Arvid Carlsson is
a new YouTube member that gets us to
three out of ten if we get 10 new
members I'll open up the phone lines and
teach me guitar says uh with a four
dollar $0.99 super Chad impeachment
seems like a necessary step in undoing
the damage
Trump has caused to our institutional
integrity don't disagree with you that
it would be justified disagree that it
can happen more quickly than the removal
of Trump by just voting for someone else
in November of 2020 okay let me now get
to this other explosive explosive story
there have been allegations made that I
have stolen the intellectual property of
fellow progressive host Sam cedar from
the majority report and let me get this
queued up where I wanted it I don't know
how it got moved as some of you will
notice the background to Sam's
set is similar in some ways to the
background at the new David Pakman show
set in the sense that the the OIC when I
switch shots it's when it's moving it so
I'll just stay on this shot for now the
three panel divider that is behind me
even though you only see two panels of
it is the same one that Sam cedar has
and in fact I asked Sam cedar for the
information about what that is and we
now have very very explosive allegations
and in fact Sam did a segment about this
on his program because he received a
call about it this is so funny let's
just take a listen to a little bit of
this I turn it on and he's reading
questions like comments and questions
but they're these YouTube super chats
that you have to pay for right okay so
by the way the beginning is even funnier
where the caller is incredulous that
people send super Jets and these
questions are just pouring in like $10 a
pop people are asking him like what do
you think about Cory Booker and somebody
paid like $10 to get him to answer that
right okay well we have a super we have
some tried to and people do that I mean
I we have the option of saying that if
you pay we will answer your question but
we prefer a lottery based system that
involves the phones where we you know I
mean if people want to tip us on super
chat more than appreciated believe me
and you know we see those figures every
week and some people really come in and
they they dump a big chunk of change for
you know once a month and you know
whatnot but so the girl Megan how much
like pay me to that respond to what
you're saying
I'm getting to the good part okay sorry
so he's he says that he has a phone
number that he's going to take calls but
that he won't do it until he gets ten
new subscribers that's right new patrons
or whatever
remember this is interesting if he's
holding he's got a gun to the phones
well he's holding them hostage right
thing and guess what he got there very
quickly and it just seems like you're
leaving a lot of money on the table my
guy well I mean I mean so what should I
do I could say like we're gonna have we
if we get 10 members I'm going to start
answering the phones today we should do
that every day like I haven't got we
haven't got 10 new members
Kelly Carey agrees with you Regan she's
trying to push this oh yeah back in the
day what the the that we do super chats
I think we su batalla yeah that would do
super chats ya know but no it's not I'm
not against it I just am NOT for it
seems like you are a boss and a
capitalist wage khakis should be all
about just putting all the money getting
all the money well I mean you can be a a
boss in a capitalist wage cut with not
necessarily being good at it I mean
that's sort of like where I packaging
myself I'm just like you know so plus my
also my feeling is like yeah good well I
also I submitted a super check because I
wanted to ask them about that there's
all this carrying on about the just
absolute outrage over super chats and
memberships and phone calls and then
he's like well I actually sent the super
check aside a question and so yeah so I
said well I said is it true that you
literally asked Sam cedar how to build
his scent and then copied it exactly and
he said yes that's a true story
wait damn like
something about it which you're not but
you should be well I'll tell you what
tell you what I'll do I tell you what I
do I will answer the question that David
has if I am saying anything about it
if he pays me so this is the sheriff's
just showed up and they have served me
with papers because there's this is now
going to potentially reach the Supreme
Court did I commit some kind of theft of
intellectual property is it theft if
someone gives it to you as Sam willingly
did but could Sam argue that it was
under duress did Sam believe that he
could say no to me right if I go to Sam
and Sam is someone I've known for years
and we work on stuff together and I say
Sam tell me how you built that set does
he actually feel as though he can say no
because if you feel as though you can't
say no the yes is really not worth very
much right so I think that this is
definitely going to be something that
will have to be fought in a court of law
we will see ultimately who ends up on
top when it comes to the legal battle
and I anticipate I anticipate that the
progressive voice and I don't know if
the progressive voice who is the de
facto progressive media TMZ of YouTube
may be covering this may be covering
this in the future and I think it will
be absolutely and completely explosive
so that's the latest with that okay and
and we'll see what ultimately happens
let me get to a couple more super chats
we have here let's take a look okay
where did I leave off you made do mosa
hilariously sends a twenty british pound
super chat saying Dave what do you think
about Cory Booker which was exactly the
question that the caller to Sam's show
claimed I was answering for money so let
me answer it for money listen I agree
with Cory Booker on many issues that's
not controversial I agree with I would
assume every single Democratic candidate
on many issues my problem with Cory
Booker is one of style and one of
since and even the style one is sort of
substantive it's that the guy just
doesn't feel genuine to me every answer
seems like a calculated a calculated
calculation that sounds so stupid it
seems like a calculated decision to not
answer the way he genuinely feels but
answer in some kind of way that he feels
will either avoid criticism or allow him
to ingratiate himself with some
significant portion of the electorate
case in point I played a clip on today's
show where he was asked by Chris
Matthews whether he thinks footballs too
dangerous and twice he refused to answer
I just answer the question Cory right
just tell us what what you think about
football is it too dangerous or isn't it
too dangerous on policy a couple things
I don't like about Booker's perspective
and he may have changed these things
since I read about them who knows maybe
he calculated that he wants to change
the idea he has floated this idea of
solving urban blight problems in urban
areas with sort of like radical
free-market capitalism just like I think
he called them Enterprise Zones and this
is a supply-side right-wing idea I just
don't agree that it's the way to solve
urban blight I've seen no evidence that
it works to solve urban blight he has
said that the way to help the tech
industry is deregulation and removing
regulation I think the last several
years have shown us that the last thing
we should be doing right now is
deregulating Silicon Valley and the tech
space so I have some disagreement with
Cory Booker he's not in my top three who
I've said on policy or Bernie Elizabeth
Warren and Andrew yang so that's that
okay Jake Alexander Jake Alexander with
a $5 super Chad says it's a clip off yes
let the segment wars between the
majority report and the David Pakman
show begin
yes it is going to be an endless sort of
inception Russian matryoshka doll
concentric circles of clips or something
like that and we could if we're lucky
Sam and I can ride this all the way to
the 2020 election
Hanson has sent a five New Zealand
dollar super chat hi David I'm a Kiwi
what do you think of our mixed-member
proportional electoral system and how do
you think it might work in the United
States I have been very interested and a
partial to those systems for a long time
but I think it has the potential to be
disastrous in the United States and I've
actually got into detail about why so I
don't want to sort of like redo the
segment now but on a personal level I
think that they are very interesting
systems and systems that I like maybe I
will do a deep dive into that at some
point in the future okay before we go
further to Jacob balls absolutely mind
blowing $50 super chat quote pouring in
as the callers to the Sam cedar show
pointed out let me welcome a new member
if you're just joining me you may not
know that this is mostly audience
supported media we do participate in
YouTube's partner program as many of you
have followed the trials and
tribulations of that program it provides
often inconsistent revenue so mostly we
fund the show through the membership
program this cuts out all middlemen okay
you got middle people even middle women
I've met some middle women and and they
they can get in the way just as much as
middlemen believe you me
membership other than the 3% payment fee
97% of every payment comes directly to
us okay
ww join pakman.com when you remember you
are supporting us directly the program
is made available to 200 radio and TV
stations for free because of the support
of membership the show is available
daily pays for staff pays for the
studios pays for equipment connectivity
the rates are very reasonable six
dollars a month or $60 for the year but
if you want to drop that by 40% apply
the coupon code
this is 2022 the membership of your
choice this is 2022 any membership and
you will save 40% you also aren't just
giving money away you get the bonus show
which is a daily show it's an extra
daily show
only for our members and patrons you
also get a commercial free version of
the entire one-hour show around 4:00
p.m. Eastern time every day no waiting
for short YouTube clips to publish every
90 minutes you get the full show around
4:00 p.m. Eastern Time okay if we get 10
new members I will open up the phone
lines we have 3 out of 10 and with the
addition of Kevin wheeler Kevin wheeler
just signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership with the coupon code this is
20 20 we are now at 4 out of 10 ok so
I'm glad to take phone calls for a while
if people want me to
we just need six more members at WWJ and
pokémon calm and I will give you a
little secret ok this is just that I
shouldn't even be mentioning this but in
February for my birthday
we ran a massive membership special and
the coupon code was saved 35 save 35
would save you $35 off of a $60
membership the coupon code is actually
still active so I'm not suggesting
anybody do this but if someone wanted to
play a dirty trick on us they could
conceivably use the coupon code save 35
and that would drop a $60 membership to
only $25 for the entire year which is
really really cheap really really cheap
ok let's get back to our super chance
Jacob all with by far the biggest super
chat of the evening with a $50 super
chat says polls are showing Sanders
Biden supporters would support the other
candidate as a second option should
their preferred candidate lose wouldn't
it make more sense for Sanders
supporters to choose Warren as a
secondary and Biden supporters to choose
bateau ok so Jacob I think the
implication that you're making is that
Elizabeth Warren's politics are closer
to Bernie's and beto O'Rourke's politics
are closer to Joe Biden's so wouldn't it
be more sensible or logical from a
merely political perspective for
Bernie Sanders supporter to say my
second choice would be Warren or for a
Joe Biden supporter to say my second
choice would be better or org and if
only policy mattered then you would be
right but in reality as a sort of
realistic pragmatic reality that's just
not the case and there are all sorts of
different reasons why a Bernie supporter
would say Joe Biden is my second choice
rather than Elizabeth Warren one of
those would be that Joe Biden is
actually very well-liked this is not my
opinion every time I say this people go
completely bonkers saying David how dare
you how dare you insult Elizabeth
Warren's likeability or Bernie's with
likability this is just from a recent
poll that spoke to Florida voters and
Democrats as well as a separate group
about likability and Joe Biden is the
most well-liked candidate right now
among the Democratic possible contenders
he hasn't even announced a candidacy yet
and if you are a Bernie supporter you
are not just going to say your second
choice based on policy you're going to
consider likability you're probably
considering electability based on the
polling I've seen electability is an
important factor so it is not policy
alone that creates this sort of
hierarchy of how people rank who they
would vote for I mean I think that if we
step back for a second Jacob the good
news from that poll which I haven't seen
by the way but I'm taking your word on
imagine if the poll doesn't even exist
and I'm commenting on something that's
made up but Jacob would never do that
the good news is that we don't seem to
be experiencing any of this my candidate
or I'm staying home or voting for Trump
stuff which is of course extraordinarily
positive to see because we don't want
that that would be exactly how Donald
Trump gets himself reelected charm
Anders sends a five-dollar super Chad 3%
GDP for the first time since 2005 if the
economy was bad you would have blamed
Trump wages up unemployment low consumer
confidence and stock market at record
high
yes oh this this is a classic Gish
gallop
okay so let's break this down first of
all 3% GDP for the first time since a 5
GDP for 2018 was 2.8 percent
far short of what Donald Trump promised
far I mean just far far short of what
Donald Trump promised also untrue that
it's the first time since 2005 I don't
know where you got those numbers I don't
know if you're talking about a specific
quarter or what you're talking about so
the first part here is just untrue this
is how the Gish Gallup works ok gifs
Gallup is you throw everything in fact
let's see if I can even put up Gish
Gallup on the screen
Gish Gallup just so we can all work with
the same definition by the way I see new
members that are signing up and I will I
will welcome them momentarily ok
Gish Gallup gifs Gallup is a technique
named after the creation is Duane Gish
who employed it whereby someone argues a
cause by hurling as many different
half-truths and no truths in a very
short space of time so their opponent
cannot hope to combat each point in real
time there's actually an additional sort
of tweak to it which is sometimes you
put them all together to make it seem
like there's this overwhelming amount of
evidence when when really there isn't so
we've already broken down 3% GDP for the
first time since a 5 if the economy was
bad you would have blamed Trump I maybe
you're talking about some other
progressive commentator I have been
consistent throughout recent presidents
in pointing out that to some degree we
attribute economic failures and
successes to the President and their
policies and to some degree there are
broader sort of systemic issues that are
going on so that allegation to make me
seem unfairly partisan is is inaccurate
wages up we are seeing some wage growth
and that is true unemployment low that
is true although remember Republicans
under Obama when unemployment was low
we're saying that low unemployment is
fake numbers the numbers are coming from
the same people now as under Obama so if
they were fake then why are they all of
a sudden real number 2
they argued under Obama that when people
stopped looking for work
the unemployment rate goes down which is
true that's the same thing under Trump
all of a sudden all of those caveats are
missing now they're just saying
unemployment rate is low and then you
know consumer confidence I don't even
think we really need to deal with you
much stock market at record highs the
Trump tax cut for corporations was used
overwhelmingly for stock buybacks which
drives up the price of stock
artificially so it's exactly what we
would expect the question is I mean
listen if you're selling everything
right now in your way up congratulations
there is every reason to think that this
is an artificial inflation of stock
prices that may or may not last so I
just sort of disagree with the entire
framing of your question um Aion says
what are your thoughts on a defense of
abortion have no idea what it is
let's look up what that is a defense of
abortion okay let's see here
a defensive abortion is a moral
philosophy paper by Judith Jarvis
Thompson Thomason first published in 71
granting for the sake of argument that
the fetus has a right to life Thompson
uses Thomson uses thought experiments to
argue that the fetus is right to life
does not Trump the pregnant woman's
right to control her own body and it's
life support functions and that induced
abortion is therefore not morally
impermissible I mean I I'd have to read
more detail to know whether I agree with
her justifications but generally
speaking that initial paragraph seems
more or less in line with with my views
art Flores says do you own any cool
vintage items no not not really I don't
own any vintage clothing that I can
think of I don't know owned any vintage
items I can't I honestly can't think of
any vintage items that I own
trickle-down
says Dave this is a very brave move on
your part kudos have you heard of the
SJW nonsense on the majority report
where they keep challenging you to a
debate
you should have Sam on and totally
destroy him in the Battle of ideas
no I haven't heard that why what people
want me to debate Sam I've heard people
want Sam to debate Dave Rubin people
want me to debate Dave Rubin people want
Sam to debate steven crowder people have
expressed a desire for me to debate ben
shapiro but I've not I've not heard a
single suggestion that I debate Sam so I
don't know if I've just missed it or or
or what what is going on okay let me
welcome another new member I'm well
considering opening up the phone lines
this evening at six one seven eight
three zero forty seven fifty but there's
a sort of if and only if there and that
if and only if is if we get ten new
members on our website at david
pakman.com slash membership when we open
the phone lines dozens of people call in
they sit on hold for a while we pay for
that every minute that each person is on
hold we pay for so we usually have a
little new membership goal on live
streams for opening up the phone lines
we are at four out of ten four out of
ten new members and I have a fifth new
member to welcome and that is Omar
Bautista Omar Bautista has signed up a
david pakman.com slash membership um
here's the thing about membership okay
and I've mentioned this before when I
started this show more than a decade ago
the goal was make it available to
everyone biggest audience possible radio
station community radio station has no
money but wants the show take the show
for free we give the show to 200 radio
and television stations etc we've talked
about the radio station piece some
portion of our audience can afford a few
bucks a month so the idea is if you can
afford to contribute to the production
of the show please do because it funds
the show for every
who can't afford to pay for it for all
of those radio stations in parts of the
country that have just right-wing talk
radio the membership program funds the
production of the show that then airs on
broadcast stations in all of those
places so if you don't have three
dollars and sixty cents a month to spare
I'm not talking to you right now
I don't want you to contribute I don't
want your last three dollars and sixty
cents a month but if the program is
worth three dollars and sixty cents a
month you and you can afford that I am
asking for your support and I asked for
that sincerely and I don't presume it or
assume it every time someone signs up it
is flattering and inspirational that
someone values what we do enough to pay
for it so on that note if you go to
david pakman.com slash membership the $6
a month drops to just three dollars and
60 cents if you use the coupon code this
is 2020 the $60 a year membership drops
to just $36 for the entire year or only
three dollars a month if you use the
coupon code this is 20 20 and if you
want like an even crazier discount you
can use the coupon code save 35 which
will drop the $60 a year membership to
just 25 bucks
I will also personally thank you on the
stream and again if folks want me to
open the phone lines and it's always
good to hear from people and some
interesting calls last week as some of
you will remember let's make it happen
and I will take phone calls for a while
but let's make it happen soon let's make
it happen soon because I don't have
unlimited time to stream but I will be
here for a while so let's make that
happen okay let's get back to Super
chats Shawn Geiss says have you ever
thought of inviting Matt Taibbi of
Rolling Stone or Noam Chomsky on your
program to discuss politics in America
they both seem to me at least the few
voices of reason in the United States
right now have invited both of them
and neither has even responded to oh
actually no no I'm Chomsky did respond
said he's very busy Matt Taibbi I don't
think
has responded to us but both are welcome
on the program anytime would love to
have them
Joe Raider Joe Raider with a twenty
dollar super set super chat says the sec
claims Elon Musk is in contempt of a
court order related to his tweeting last
year for his latest tweets regarding
Tesla his lawyers responded with the
First Amendment argument visa V SEC
overreach any thoughts yes we are
talking about that on the bonus show
this week so we are going to be delving
into that in some detail and I look
forward to discussing that on the bonus
show but we will absolutely be talking
about that by the way let me just
address because you mentioned Elon Musk
years ago on the program I announced I
guess we could call it an announcement
that I owned Tesla stock okay I wasn't
like a super early investor in it but I
got in it years ago I mean relatively
early enough that that there there was a
nice return being made and I would
mention every time Tesla came up often
negatively by the way that I own some
Tesla stock and the consensus from
people in the audience was David you
know you don't really own that much
Tesla stock what you're saying is not
moving the needle on the stock price you
don't really need to mention that you
own test the stock every time you pop it
comes up so I did a story like a year
and a half ago or two where I didn't
disclose that I owned Tesla stock I got
like a dozen emails from furious people
saying I even though it was a story that
was negative about Tesla like if I was
trying to bump the stock price I
wouldn't even do the story but people
furious furious and David I cannot
believe that you did not disclose your
ownership of Tesla stock and so then I
sort of like went back to disclosing
ownership of Tesla stock and then again
people started writing and saying David
it's really annoying to hear you mention
that every time are you bragging or
something like that and of course the
answer is no I'm just kind of trying to
do the right thing here do you want me
to mention
don't you so we're also going to discuss
on the bonus show this issue of the
Tesla stock disclosures and I will
mention to you that when you on musk
went on I think it was when he went on
the Joe Rogan show smoked pot which I
don't care about but it started a whole
hubbub
about is this guy gonna cause a decline
in the stock price or whatever I did
sell half of my Tesla stock sold half
the stock still have half of it and
that's my story I don't know even cares
what stocks I own come on okay
Paul pagoda sends a six dollar sixty six
cents super Chet who is someone you
would really love to have on your show
but they refused
conversely who would you refuse if
anyone well I'd refuse anybody that I
don't think would be good for or
interesting for the audience and that's
a lot of people we get guest pitches
every day ten fifteen guests or pitch to
me every day across all platforms most
of them get rejected
who would I love to have on but they
refuse I would love to interview Barack
Obama it's not even a thing of he's
refused I I assume that it's just a
non-starter although I admit we've not
really tried other than a couple of
times early in his presidency we've not
really tried to get Barack Obama on the
show I believe that it would be
difficult to do that although I would
love to interview him new-made you mosa
sends a ten British pound super chat
thank you very much charm Anders says
2018 GDP growth highest since oh five
Google it live I mean that's just not
true we covered that very recently and I
will do a followed I have a new video on
it on the YouTube channel Sean dice says
should the green New Deal be framed as a
free-market argument to the right they
seem to talk about the marketplace
determining how society functions but
the rest of the world is moving green
yeah you know Sean this is there's an
underlying debate here that is implied
by your question which is when the left
has something they want to do and they
want to try to convince the right to go
along with it should we argue on the
basis of our values or should we try to
frame our positions on the basis of
their values so should we try to frame I
don't know should we try to frame
climate change on the basis of national
security or patriotism for example I
don't know the answer to that when I
interviewed Nathan J Robinson he said he
doesn't think that that's a good idea
I've interviewed other people who think
that it is a good idea to try to frame
debates based on the morals of those who
you are trying to convince I don't know
that the green New Deal framed as free
market is going to convince the right I
think because here's the thing the right
doesn't actually care about free markets
right Trump says I'm gonna reinvigorate
coal which could only be done by
violating the free market principles
that would have coal totally die
they don't care if they want to
revitalize coal they're going to do it
by violating free-market principles not
by adhering to them because they don't
actually give a [ __ ] about the free
market principle they want to support
what they've already decided is the
policy that they want so no I don't
think that the green new deal could be
successfully sold to the right along
those lines Jackson says if calls cost
money per minute maybe consider counting
super chats towards the goal I'm already
a member but I want to contribute
towards calls that's an interesting idea
Jackson uh I'd have to think about
exactly what the logistics of it are
maybe we would have like a dollar target
for super chats or something like that
something to think about I will take it
under advisement Augustine says
Elizabeth Warren really killed her own
chances of becoming president when she
took that DNA test and thought being one
one thousand twenty-fourth Native
American was a win I have said before
Augustine that I believe Elizabeth
Warren mishandled that entire thing I do
call it a fiasco at this point and I
think it definitely has hurt her chances
of becoming the Democratic nominee but
we will see I've been wrong before and I
could be wrong again okay let me say
thank you to a few new members Dylan
door
is this evenings sixth new member of the
evening Sara
Elmen is new member number seven Sara
thank you so much for signing up
Cheryl Hoffman is new member number
eight of the evening Cheryl thank you
very much and Brian Tracy is new member
number nine
Brian thank you thank you one more new
member and I will open up the phone
lines at six one seven eight three zero
forty seven fifty if people want the
phone lines opened this is the time I
think if it goes too much longer it just
won't be worth opening them up but let's
uh I will open up the phone lines
immediately if we get one more new
member at david pakman.com slash
membership a Kyle Priam says with
Trump's cognitive decline getting worse
by the day any concerns with vernie's
age being an issue no particular
concerns
no particular concerns we've not seen
the pattern with Bernie that we have
seen with Donald Trump so no I don't
have any particular concern with that at
this point in time although I think it's
perfectly legitimate to consider age as
a factor in thinking about who we
support in any election Jackson says I
don't typically side with billionaires
against the government but it seems to
me that the SEC is overreaching I've
been following it closely sad yeah I'll
analyze the Tesla SEC story it is a very
interesting story for sure Sabrina Zafar
says what issue will be most decisive in
2020 I think it's going to be much more
generally one's approach to the economy
and that it's so broad it can encompass
so many things economic justice taxes
medica Medicare for all versus how
health care should be funded I think
that much more than for example during
george w bush's reelection campaign the
war in Iraq and geopolitics were a big
factor I think with Trump beyond the
influence that Russian meddling
collusion obstruction whatever you want
to call it will be there as a factor and
that's obviously an international story
I think it's going to be domestic
economic issues that are going to be
really important for the 2020 election
Joshua car with a twenty British pound
super judge do you think capitalism
could be sustained in a society that was
entirely virtuous very philosophical
question it's very pie in the sky but I
sort of think the answer is yes where
capitalism goes wrong is that if it's
unregulated if it is not capitalism in
the mode of Scandinavian countries human
nature becomes a factor that is
oppressive based on the socio-economic
relationships that develop in a
capitalist system so you might hear me
say that and say that that sounds like
you're a socialist David I'm not I'm for
regulated capitalism I'm for capitalism
that allows the good parts of capitalism
to be positive influences in society
while recognizing that these sort of
libertarian paradises are merely
imaginary utopia's that need to be
controlled so yeah I think in this
hypothetical world where homo sapiens is
entirely virtuous and selfless almost to
some degree capitalism may not need the
the regulation that clearly it needs is
that ever going to happen only if humans
changed very very significantly okay
John Dobson has signed up at david
pakman.com slash memberships so a
membership that is so let's take some
phone calls you can call in at six one
seven eight three zero forty seven fifty
I will take a few phone calls although
it's getting a little late in the game
we didn't we didn't get the phone lines
open too quickly today but I will take
some phone calls at six one seven eight
three zero forty seven fifty if you want
to call in a please please do not be on
speaker phone no speaker phone no
speaker phone I don't know how many how
many times I have to say that people
seem to forget okay I'll deal with this
one other super chat
and then we'll get to the phones Daniel
ved burg cyclic says what's so what's
your own estimated ETA on when if ever
Trump would be charged and/or indicted
for a criminal charge at best I see a
post 20/20 charge but I don't know yeah
I'm not even thinking about it Daniel
I think it's extraordinarily unlikely
that Donald Trump is going to be charged
I think as a political strategy we
shouldn't even be thinking about it
vote him out November of 2020 period I
mean that doesn't mean impeachment is
not a worthy cause or the correct thing
doesn't mean removal under the 25th
amendment would be outrageous it just
means it's unlikely to happen and we
need to we need to do everything we can
to just get the guy out okay let's go to
the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 why
don't we go first
oh you know who's on the phone
everybody's favorite Trumpets Jimmy from
Philly is on the phone and I'm always
curious about what Jimmy from Philly
Jimmy from Philly is all over the
YouTube comments very very aggressively
he's what you might call a YouTube
provocateur Jimmy what's going on what
do you have for me today hey Jimmy are
you there you're on the phone not to
much David what's going on Jimmy what do
you have for me today yeah I got you now
can you hear me I can hear you okay oh
let me come in this what's going on well
you know you're just disingenuous as
ever
okay do you know what disingenuous means
yes it means not genuine okay and in
which way am I not dead David the other
day you got a 13% tax raise basically
and you still found a way to complain
about Trump no I got a tax cut not a tax
raise tax cut what it's the same damn
thing David there you go again not all
you in a good place being disingenuous
Jimmy it wouldn't a tax raise be my
taxes went up butter this is not what
that means I don't
know what you're talking about I'm not
even trying to argue you do know what
I'm talking about I may have misspoke
David but come on come on David
so what's your question I really have a
question like I've been watching your
shows and man it's hard why won't you
debate the hard bastard sorry who the
hard bastard the hard bastard is that is
that yes'm
yes he's read you every week I'm sure
you've heard about them I don't know
what on earth you're talking about this
is a broad hard bastard he's on YouTube
he does what he does um the live streams
like you're doing right now three times
a week and he goes over a couple things
you talk about least twice a week and
shred you what shame so there's a guy
doing three streams a week and in two
out of three the 3 streams he's talking
about me now I didn't say that he but at
least twice a week don't do a short
segment on something that you're talking
about
huh and wow I didn't miss Reggie David
David David he put you to shame
so what topic does he want to debate
with me I'm not sure but I know you were
offered $2,000 in terms of damn I was
offered $2,000 to debate the hard
bastard that's what I heard ok I don't
know anything about it my friend would
you debate him I have no idea who it is
so I could not possibly here's the thing
he won't the big in three or four
minutes like you do with cars and then
you get rid of them you know how you do
that now he wants a full hour ok and
what I don't think you could withstand
um I really don't but ok Jimmy I'm
curious what kind of work do you do just
generally I'm a landscaper ok and are
you ever this angry with your landscape
customers what makes you think I'm an
angry right now David well every time
you've called in you're furious every
time first of all this is the second
time day that's right ok so you know I
don't know if every time is well the
appropriate thing to say here the second
time what all right so anyways they're
not angry when your landscaping is what
you're saying
now I look only when I hear left this
with with garbage like you coming out of
your mouth I mean it's unbelievable so
why even get money on tax card Jimmy you
know complaining if it winds you up so
much why bother watching right I mean
just watch something else I get
enjoyment out of this oh you do open but
are you angry when you enjoy you having
fun right now David you couldn't wait to
pick up the fine knew you would see my
area code and pick it up I do it Oh area
code Jimmy we've got an entire file on
you in our system it's not area I'm sure
you think I'm not important but if you
do all right I see you in the YouTube
comments my friend thank you very much
for the call okay let's get someone new
on let's get someone from the seven one
six area code caller from seven one six
who's this where you calling from what's
on your mind today
hey David it's me that is you yeah oh
yeah my name is Josiah hey how's it
going did you say your name is Jill
Stein Josiah Josiah
I'm so sorry okay I misheard that thank
you you didn't sound like the last time
I spoke to Jill Stein I was gonna say
what's coming but I have two quick
questions if you got the time of course
question one is a question I thought had
about medicare-for-all because I really
do support it yeah what happens to
medicare-for-all when the government
shuts down like what happened if we do
get it in and then we get another Trump
who wants to shut the government down
for way longer very good so if it's
truly an expansion of the Medicare
system we have now that system continued
functioning during the shutdown so if
we're just expanding it then it's okay
if things change and Medicare means
something different than what it is now
then then potentially it would be
impacted but Medicare to my knowledge
was not impacted by the government
shutdown gotcha
all right and my second question is um
with the climate reports that were
receiving telling us that we only have
about 12 years before we get to the
irreversible impacts on the
how do we continue to fight the
onslaught of anti science headed by the
Republican Party in a called fashionable
way when we lose that time every year we
hold up right listen they don't deserve
a seat at the table that's the reality
so this is number one unfortunately
other countries are right to not include
the Trump administration in the
discussions about climate change because
Trump thinks it's a hoax how do you even
justify having someone with that point
of view at the table I want us to have a
president that believes all the science
but more importantly under media media
needs to stop playing the 50/50 false
neutrality game right yeah we know what
the science is so stop the 1vs1 debates
where one person says it's real and the
other person says it doesn't that's
irresponsible at this point yeah now I
would agree with you um but um sadly the
fact is that they do have a stake in
this it's we share the one planet it's
kind of like we're tethered to the
screaming kid on the plane and we can't
get rid of them that's right well listen
I'm fine with taking steps that will
benefit everybody even if they don't
believe the climate science but what I'm
saying is I think that we're going to
need to get around them in order to get
serious solution that that's all I mean
okay sorry I misunderstood yep no
problem
all right Josiah thank you so much for
the call very much appreciate it
let's see let's go next to our caller
from the six one zero area code who's
calling today from six one zero this is
Ken from Allentown hey Ken what's going
on yeah I guess to see your opinion
about uh I can't say for like guys
impeaching Trump or get him out before
before the election like like we
shouldn't we should just vote him out
but um I I agree with that
but what are your thoughts on I think
it's better he's in there for for the
2020 election only because I feel like
him in there now kind of splits the
Republican vote like those that are like
the Republicans that are kind of
how can I say more reasonable probably
won't vote for him if he's in office but
if he would be I guess impeached or
indicted or kicked out or whatever
that uh names like somebody like like
tense over ever the other candidate
would be would probably then get all the
Republican votes back yeah that's fair
that's a fair point I think that the the
removal of Trump between now in the
election would be such a detriment and
embarrassment for the Republican Party
that I don't know that all the
Republicans say great now let's vote for
Pence in order to prevent some Democrat
from being in the Oval Office I don't
think what you're bringing up is
impossible I'm just not sure that the
numbers bear it out but it's certainly a
strong argument to say that a
scandal-ridden Trump all the way to
November of 2020 may be the best bet to
get a Democrat inaugurated in January of
2021 I just haven't seen numbers on it
that would make me confident one way or
the other
thanks for taking okay very good
appreciate the call thank you I see that
Renee plays Ola has signed up as a new
Youtube subscriber thank you very much
Renee I appreciate that
Daniel vet Berg cyclic is asking are
there call restrictions on where people
can call from you can call from anywhere
if you call six one seven eight three
zero
4750 want to say welcome to Karen
Ledesma who is our newest david pakman
show member signed up just minutes ago
and brian Ferren sends a super chat
asking thoughts on the importance of
STEM education extraordinarily important
us increasingly falling behind in math
science so many fields that are going to
be of extreme importance as we continue
the sort of technological revolution and
that's really what it is that we've been
in for the last to some degree hundred
and fifty years in some sense the last
fifty in a more acute sense
20 years absolutely massively important
can't disconnect it from the issue of
the cost of college I mean it's not
sustainable and I've ranted about this
before something's going to have to
change the cost of college is simply not
sustainable and we're hurting ourselves
with college costing what it costs let's
go next to our caller from the 206 area
code whose calling today from 206 hey
David this is Bryan from Seattle hey
Bryan what's going on hey well first of
all it's an honor to get to talk to you
of been watching your show for a while
and I think you say what you do I want
to do real briefly like I don't want to
get into this whole you know majority
report thing because I mean the reality
is the whole thing is kind of a joke and
horses but but real briefly like just to
give you some context the guy that that
was actually calling in and as a bunch
of people I saw in your chatter familiar
is a guy that goes by Ronald Reagan that
calls in the majority report all the
time and he's a smart guy he's an
immigration attorney so they he
discusses issues a lot of the time about
the border wall and that you know ice
and things like that and he's a smart
guy and he has a lot of interesting
things to say I also think he is used to
getting straight through on the maturity
report because they know him and he has
a lot to say about topics and I kind of
feel like the issue comes down to David
Pakman doesn't let me immediately get
through and talk so he's holding
everyone hostage in other words that
this is a personal gripe that he doesn't
like that he yeah yeah I mean it's not
even so much personal is I think he has
become kind of entitled to bit like his
voice gets to get through he gets to get
priority on air which and you know in
that context that he's an immigration
attorney and he has very direct relevant
things to say that that makes sense but
you're not the majority reported you
don't know him he and it's my other
issue with that that argument and you
know again I'll keep this brief because
the whole thing is kind of silly and I
want to give it too much weight my other
thing is it would be one thing if you
were saying I'm not going to do my show
today unless I get you know 10 new
members and today it's a live stream all
you're saying is like this is
to me it's the equivalent of when NPR
does a pledge drive and they say we want
your support and also we'll give you
this mug a lot you know you're not
saying this mug is worth your $100 or
whatever donation you're saying here's a
bonus if we get to this point you know
absolutely it's an optional piece of
content it's not alright I'm gonna quit
doing my show if you guys don't get it
like no that would be a different
argument right I appreciate the defense
I had not that it was necessary but more
importantly if Ronald Reagan called it a
show once and then identified themselves
as Ronald Reagan and then we put him in
our caller ID system as Ronald Reagan
and Mark him a caller then I would
actually see him pop up and maybe he
would get on the phones right so I mean
I don't know this guy's ever called in
to the show right and my and my last
thing I'll say about that and then I'll
let you get on the other colors because
you know I don't want people to get a
chance to get on is you know it the
thing with that is just you know
actually I mean it forgotten my point so
good let's go out on a high note and
really appreciate the clock then I will
put you into the system as Brian from
Seattle good caller and now you will be
able to get in more quickly how about
that for Ronald Reagan or whoever the
guy is all right good okay thanks very
much appreciate the call okay the
progressive voice has arrived who has
more swag you or cedar I don't even know
what you mean like who sells more items
I'd have no idea I don't know what Sam
has we've got coffee coffee mugs
t-shirts hoodies bumper stickers
memberships I might be misinterpreting
the question and response to Carl I
don't even know what that means
I'm guessing just because it's the
progressive voice that you mean Carl
Benjamin known as Sargon Sargon of Akkad
I don't know I don't even know what he's
done I don't even know why I should be
responding to him okay let's go next to
wow we have a lot of international
callers let's just get crazy and go to
country code 50
I have absolutely no idea what country
code 53 is but who's there from country
code 53 I'm sorry it's country code 52
yeah oh hi can you hear me
I can't who's this where you calling
from hi I'm Marco I'm calling from
Puerto Vallarta Mexico okay great love
Mexico
yeah so two months ago the new president
was elected a limo and I was working
like what was your opinion on on him or
if you had an opinion at all well I have
some knowledge I like a lot of his ideas
regarding sort of getting cronyism and
elitism out of government and I remember
there was like a big thing about the
private plane stuff right like he wasn't
gonna use a private plane yeah and be
flying on on Aeromexico has he been
doing that I feel like without knowing
exactly what the policy changes have
been it felt like an interesting
direction for the Mexican presidency but
I really couldn't make any kind of
serious analysis of how he's doing on
policy I mean what do you think how is
he doing well what I think like he's had
some interesting like ideas like
decisions like he cancelled the 13
billion dollar Airport project in Mexico
City it was gonna be the second biggest
airport in the world and the biggest in
the Western Hemisphere and a lot of
people who are in the upper class of
Mexico are really upset about it so it
seems like the majority of the
population was pretty well like well
agreed with it and I agreed with it so
I'll be good yeah Wow all right well I
need to follow Mexican politics more
closely and by the way Marco how is it
that you have a perfect phone connection
and I have people calling from the same
city I'm in and it sounds like they're
in a submarine I just don't understand
how is your connection so good well
maybe cuz I have a lemon ah well there
it is that that explains it Marco really
appreciate the call
wait to hear from you first caller we've
ever had from Mexico let's just to stick
with the international theme let's go to
our caller I think that this is country
code 46 is that is am I reading that
correctly that would be correctly I am
from Sweden oh okay very good
what's your name my name is Daniel and
I'm calling from
I said cold cold North in Sweden or more
specific Gothenburg swith them very nice
what's on your mind today on my mind
today is the ever-present issue at least
for us woods but not necessarily
smashing Americans the blame shifting
again Scandinavians and how it impacts
us from the USA or the right so to say
not very what what form I have 50 going
on I'm referring to like the influx of
right we put began but to make Sudan
look bad so just calling us a socialist
country oh yeah
degrading us in the comparison to other
countries now somewhat of a weird
tradition as someone who lives in Sweden
if some right-wingers in the u.s.
incorrectly think Sweden is socialist
does it really affect your life in any
way or does it not really matter to be
honest it has refer believe it had
reverberated in our society become a
talking point of our own right-wing
parties actually really generally
speaking what the right-wing years of
the u.s. three years ago started more or
less blaming us for or claiming has
become the the chance of the right-wing
is with it in real time because this
ball suddenly if told the same thing
plenty of times will believe it
eventually interesting that that is a
very interesting perspective and
fascinating that your own rights is sort
of taking a page out of the notebook of
the American right which is
extraordinarily extraordinarily
uninformed there very interesting
insights Daniel I appreciate it
and same here I mean if anything else
want to clarify if the most basic things
would were rather than basic
misconception of Sweden such as the
supposed immigrant innovation I just
want to point out there is less Muslim
in our country than there is in most of
the minor cities in the u.s. we have
less than 100 cells and practicing
absalom in our country absolutely now
the problem is hilarious here people
claim things about so here's the thing
the right will make conflicting
arguments about immigration in Sweden if
they want to move when when people on
the Left say look at how well Sweden's
doing the right will say they're doing
well because they have so few immigrants
and it's all white people but then when
they want to criticize Sweden they will
say Sweden's a disaster look at all
these brown Muslim people that are
invading how can both be true it's it's
one of these just amazing double
standards that exists yeah I mean in
this case is even more ridiculous when
you actually go to the Swedish politics
of things to put it lightly in Sweden
they'll talk about this kaká culture or
wisdom of the manlihood there whatever
you want to call it that we're getting
softer as a nation due to the
progressive ideas where expelling
outwards right it has come to bite us in
the ass because we haven't had the
strongest politicians due to the fact
that it took us almost a year just get
up actual ruling party in place and
rather a majority government another
story for another day but to put it
bluntly Sweden has been this late in a
extreme cultural and social revolution
of say where people have become
generally more extreme and rather
right-wing in their opinions about
things
judging rather than being very open as
we used to be doing very closed society
duteous this wage you're getting from
the right world simply you just look at
Europe and how many countries can't lift
anymore and that has tells a lot of
social democracy more less falling apart
on upon itself to the
new rights wave or whatever you wanna
call it yeah I just read a very
interesting history of the Swedish
Social Democratic Party and it's
interesting to see how how things are
shifting there
Daniel thank you very much Paul I
appreciate it I've got a bunch of people
to get to so I will let you go but
really great to hear from you let me see
who else I can pick up on here let's
maybe go to our caller from the 2:01
area code caller from 2:01 who's there
today yes
so who's this who's calling where you
calling from what kind of dog is that
but a Roselli I just want to have a
quick talk with you already yeah tried
try to speak up if you can because we've
got you maxed out on our end and it's
very difficult to hear you sure can hear
me better oh yeah a little bit okay so
yeah um I just have a couple questions
for you okay so I'm something I'm kind
of concerned about it's the way right
away in propaganda is like taking
everything that's happening in the
moment and just enough to completely to
see the viewers who aren't trying to put
more effort into learning everything
else about the story I just hear the
personalities talk about it right I mean
it shows them right away and that
continues I don't see how we can get
back to them so if I understand
correctly you're saying that the right
has they'll take a situation and they
will sort of like repackage it and pull
out a grain of truth that might be true
but very distorted and going reveal that
in order to create a narrative that's
favorable to them exactly yeah I mean
that's not new I I think that it's being
there's a bigger echo chamber right now
especially when you've got like the
Trump administration and Fox News
Hannity's talking to Trump on the phone
and Trump saying Jeanine Pirro is great
and they're just all repeating each
other
I think the echo chamber
is maybe more powerful but the idea of
pulling out some grain of truth and that
is extraordinarily not representative of
reality is not a new tactic it's always
been happening yeah yeah I mean maybe
not Ellie I'm gonna let you go because
you sound like you're underwater you
sound like the teacher and peanuts so
I'm gonna let you go it's it's crazy
what's going on but I appreciate the
call and I think you're pointing out a
very important thing for for sure let's
go to the nine five one area code caller
from nine five one who's there today uh
hi this is Robert Betancourt I am the
one that's doing the North Shore Yacht
Club Mekka
California on the Salton Sea we have a
meeting of the sole authority scheduled
for the 28th of March 10 o'clock sorry
Robert let me see if we can just back up
just a hair here so you you said you're
calling from from California you said
right yes okay and you're calling from
what organization I am one of those it's
got a proposed project which is twelve
years old it's on the North Shore Yacht
Club and 99 one five see you drive Mecca
California on the Salton Sea and what is
it so you're this is a yachting related
thing no this is because there's like a
23% unemployment on the song sea side
because of the lake being dried up in
the dust the silicon dust which has
created a lot of respiratory problems
and Robert I would have to keep
interrupting you but this is which which
lake is this in reference to the Salton
Sea which is Southern California I know
with Breitbart news they
put it as only one mile but it's
actually 22 kilometers long 15
kilometers wide and 1.5 kilometers deep
it is the largest lake in the western
United States and it's called the salt
and sea is the name of the lake called
sa LTO in the Salton Sea oh I was
imagining the salt and sea the Salton
Sea
okay and you've organized the meeting of
the minds around this issue is what
you're telling me I'm one of those that
work with the ten directors on the
Salton Sea authority okay
the website is Salton Sea Authority or
core G and we've been doing this I think
the salt and sea Authority is now almost
50 years old
at this time we have a plan to maintain
the shoreline back to where were des now
and stop the raising the silicon dust
from where the Salton Sea was no it was
not created entirely by an accident okay
no and I never said that it was and
Robert III don't want to is there a
particular question that you had because
I don't think you know most of our
audience is not in physical proximity to
where you're talking about
so it was there a question you had it's
just sort of a general bulletin board
notice my question is is what we're
going to do on next Thursday as we want
to oppose recognizing the Salton Sea
Authority which receives federal funds
to be a federal agency and then we can
go through dr MO so those who don't know
that's deep
defense reutilization material office
which this president has created a lot
of excess surplus including for 860
patrol boats that are brand-new that
Robert this doesn't sound like a
question
in the audience I really I mean people
are dropping like flies here is their
what let's is there a website people can
go to let's put it that way
Salton Sea authority org brilliant
Salton Sea authority org Robert I
appreciate the call and and wish you the
best only the best in everything that
you're doing there Zak Hanratty sent the
super Chad hey David what are your new
sources for daily news to start your day
prepping for your show I appreciate you
man I have built a private sort of like
homepage that aggregates a whole bunch
of different news sources and there are
dozens and dozens I wouldn't want to
list any because I would be excluding
some but there's a lot of the ones that
you would imagine and then some kind of
more niche blogs but maybe I'll do I'll
publish my full source list
Daniel vet berg cyclic says I'd love to
have a more in discussion debate if time
allows it in the future especially on us
euro
bowls view of how things are going and
affects us absolutely Daniel I would
love that
Matthew Upchurch says David what's your
go-to karaoke song
I don't think karaoke so I don't have
one our progressives at karaoke group in
Indianapolis looks forward to a visit
from the pac-man in the near future
I am scheduling public speaking
appearances for 2019 currently bs says
what happens if donald trump tries to
use a Reichstag fire like event to
suspend the 2020 election I don't think
he's gonna do that so let's let's cross
that bridge when we when it comes when
we come to it the same question seems to
have been repeated there okay let's go
next to the two six seven area code
who's calling today from 267 pitted
strong guys from Philadelphia hey Sean
what's going on nothing much I hope not
to be as ferocious as my fellow
Philadelphians Jimmy from here I hope to
have a rational talk with you right now
so my question is relating to the future
of American government and the policies
bad could be set for a future because
what I'm worried about and I'm wondering
if you had this thought too
that in the future that the current or
the folks are the future Congress that
will have will put forward you know
bills that are against the American
people you know things that you know
that seem to happen today like they
support corporations and you know they
try to put and they prevent things such
as Medicare for all cetera and they'll
use a sort of trump card to sort of say
well listen you see what you know Donald
Trump did you know when he was president
you know it was horrible because it
seems like it could be a big neoliberal
thing like this like the neoliberal
middle-of-the-road sort of so I'm put my
words get a sort of uh sort of thing on
Bill like you know how they'll do they
listen we're not as bad as the as the
right but you saw how Trump was horrible
do you want to have no do you understand
what I'm saying I don't I don't I
apologize what what is the sort of
question I guess I kind of understand
some of the framing well the framing I'm
saying is that the future American
government will say you know we'll put
together bad bills or bad policies
together like say on the environment
like it'll be a half-measure sort of
thing yeah to fully heal the environment
as an example and they'll say we'll
listen Trump you know he opened all
these Arctic drillings he did this that
with the environment do you want to do
you want to have another Trump scenario
and they'll try to use like a sort of
scary trump card in the future to put
forward half a spell so to say well you
know what I mean now I still don't know
I mean if it's a bit if it's if the bill
is a step in the right direction instead
of two steps it's still in the right
direction right
yeah no you're absolutely right about
that but I'm thinking there they'll use
that purposely to not go all the way
forward on a bill that could help you
know entirely that's what I mean I guess
it's possible I guess it's possible but
I don't think that that is the the
primary sort of a scary scenario that I
would be thinking of as a result of a
disastrous Trump presidency but I guess
it's it's conceivable Sean I appreciate
the call thank you very much a couple
other super chats
to mention third int dent says do you
use a third party to run your phone
lines yes we do we've got a whole system
in place a whole extraordinary system a
Dylan Collett says has Andrew yang eased
any of your concerns about ubi support
from tech entrepreneurs and how they
stand to benefit from the next wave of
automation no he hasn't
I'm not against ubi but Andrew yang has
not eased those concerns at least to
date and we're hoping to have him back
on the program soon and maybe then he
will ease some of those concerns all
right that's it for today sorry
everybody I couldn't get to I've got to
run a new show tomorrow and a whole
bunch of great stuff coming up thanks to
everybody who joined me will stream
again very soon